wow der besteht dass die youtuber
deutschland ist zurück meine lieben
freunde herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen video auf einem kanal
ich habe mir gedacht mensch es schneit
ich brauche einen t3 fahren wir jetzt im
teeladen ja warum habe ich jetzt hier
auch nochmal gestartet ich bin das jetzt
zehn minuten darf mal wie schön das hier
ist mit dem schneider gute liegt fast
gar nichts
scheißegal ich bin jetzt auch in einer
minute da ist man dann sehen uns wieder
mit elan meines vertrauens darüber
geschlossen
[Musik]
denn erst dann habe ich im auto
irgendwie aus oder anziehen das geht gar
nicht wir brauchen jetzt auf jeden fall
einen neuen laden wo ich mit tee holen
kann es gelbe halten auf starbucks sie
haben auf jeden fall offen warum
streicht du dein haus pink zurück zum
sport modus heraus zurück zum
wesentlichen thema meine lieben freunde
ich brauche t mir ist das kalt ich
könnte ihnen halt machen
ich habe halt lenkradheizung dafür nicht
links es gibt in hamburg einfach so eine
straße die heißt sierichstraße dies zu
einer gewissen zeit am tag davor nun die
einrichtung fahren und dann wenn die
zeit umgekehrt ist also die einrichtung
ist dann befahrbar und die andere
richtung spa sie einbahnstraße also das
halt nicht rein das jetzt gerade der
fall das heißt ich will eigentlich in
die stadt rein muss jetzt aber wieder
nach winterhude rein
ich hasse das wenn die neben dem autor
über kuppen und sich zu denken da möchte
ich an dem kamera
ja ich war grad bei starbucks und haben
einfach ausgeschlossen
wie findet ihr die brille also die werde
ich niemals kaufen weil dies zu
kartieren diesen befehl zu teuer aber
ich musste gerade testen wegen der
stärke aber ist nicht so schlimm in
starbucks weil real talk immer wenn ich
in diesem laden bin fragen mich die
mädels wir arbeiten einfach meinen namen
ja das ist doch auch schön jetzt machen
wir ja heute so einen kleinen ausflug
aus hamburg mein gott sie kommt rein ins
auto zu früh jetzt mal einfach so jetzt
hab ich mit ihnen den rat am telefon
sprechen weil der rechts neben mir und
links neben mir die schau mir gehörig in
die kariya den deal für 20 millionen
müssen auf jeden fall noch diese woche
umsetzen hier wird das deutschlandhaus
gebaut keine ahnung warum das so heiß
ich werde die a klasse nie verstehen das
auto ist höher als das ist breit ist
schon fest eine enge kurve und fällt
einfach um
hier vorne haben wir jetzt den
platz mit einer statue drauf ich drehe
ich möchte kann man rauchen dann wird ja
auch mal ein bisschen was schönes ich
weiß nicht ob das jetzt vielleicht
richtig dumm klingt aber falls ihr
schonmal auto gefahren sei und
dementsprechend auch über 18 sein oder
über 70 schon wieder
voll oft wenn ich einfach so auto fahre
denke ich mir ich fahre rad auto wenn
jetzt so mache dann bin ich das einfach
ich habe eigentlich ein thema was ich
mit euch heute berufen wollte eigentlich
wirklich was zu bereden mit euch und ich
dachte mir luca bevor du alleine zu
hause in der bruchbude sitzt und dich
dabei aufnimmst wie hinter denen weiße
wand ist ich fahre - und jetzt also
komplett wir und ich weiß nicht was ich
mit denen machen soll deswegen am besten
eigentlich mit kapuzen sie ganz ändern
weil er sich entweder aus wie ein zwerg
oder ein schwerverbrecher dem autobauer
ich kann heute nicht an heute moment ich
muss euch das zeigen ich bin drin
ich bin drin
ich bin drin beim ersten mal kennt ihr
diese auf dem rollator sitzt also die
setzen sich irgendwohin mitten in die
stadt um sitzen dann gucken sie guckt
gerade wer perfekt eingeführt die haben
einfach ausgeschlossen ich kaufe ein
parkticket für 30 minuten für sechs euro
und der laden hatte geschlafen ich trage
zu einem starbucks erst geschlossenen
schadet davor bin ich sogar noch zu
meinem sohn zähler an des patrons
gefahrene mittwoch wieder aufgeschlossen
man ist das ist halt das ist 1630 keine
ahnung vielleicht schießen die alle
irgendwie schon 15 das heißt ich mein
alter ich danke euch jetzt wie ich mir
dieses video ja eigentlich vorgestellt
hatte ich hole mir ein thema in meinem
land in winterhude war irgendwo hin an
den schönen ort setzt mich dann mein
auto wir schauen uns den schnee ein
bisschen so wie hintergrund und ich
erzähle aber mein thema
jetzt sind wir wieder einen schönen ort
noch habe ich ein t aber wir haben ein
thema um dem thema ist auch tele ring
also
ich liebe diese geräusche aber ich habe
ein thema was fällt euch besprechen
möchte meine rolle und zwar habe ich bei
mädchen gesehen in hamburg und brauche
hilfe
das sieht schon ziemlich scheiße also
folgende situation ich war in hamburg
unterrichtet ganz kurz auf dem navi
zeigen ich habe auf jeden fall von hier
war auf einem fahrrad unterwegs und habe
hier das mit melanom das ding heißt auf
jeden fall hier stand ein mädchen vor
mit ich hoffe ihrem bruder weil die
seien sich sehr ähnlich und ich bin mir
vorbeigelaufen und kennt ihr das wenn
ihr also an einer person vorbeiläuft und
ihr denkt okay
und dann dreht ihr euch irgendwie
nochmal um so nach ein paar metern ich
hab mich umgedreht und dann hat sie
wieder zu ihrem bruder geguckt und ich
bin heute auch weiter gegangen und ich
brauche meine bitte an euch meine lieben
freunde kennt ihr sei ein mädchen mit
einem bruder
wenn du das mädchen das ihr denen sollen
solche würde es nach der bitte melde
dich bei mir telefonisch unter 0 13
ich bin so verzweifelt ja
wie hat euch unser stadt tritt plätze
gefallen
ich glaube man hat noch nie bei einem
städtetrip so wenig von einer stadt
gesehen wie bei mir jetzt heute
ganz kurz von fact immer wenn ich
anfange zu singen tränen meine augen ist
das normal oder ist das einfach weiß ich
mein gehirn denkt ja da muss ich wollen
so schlecht wie tony marshall schaut
euch mal an wie die bands klicks wie
solchen da bitte reinfahren was ich noch
sagen wollte war dass ich jetzt nicht
irgendwie groß verzweifelt rechts
abbiegen und sofort die richtzeiten was
ich noch sagen wollte war dass ich jetzt
nicht irgendwie großartig verzweifelt
rüberkommen möchte in diesem video in
stoßzeiten und sofort wieder rechts
abbiegen
man sitzt rechts abbiegen ja ich habe
verstanden was ich noch sagen wollte war
dass ich jetzt nicht was ich wohl noch
sagen wollte ich mir dafür die ganze
zeit unterbrochen hatte war ganz einfach
das was wir hier nicht irgendwie doof
rüberkommen soll bei euch von wegen
lukas braucht seine zielgruppe
herauszufinden wer dieses mädchen da
irgendwie war aber wenn ihr vielleicht
jemanden kennt der blond braun ist circa
170 ein bruder hat und dort am 9.9
unterwegs sondern euch gerne ich glaube
wenn die personen das hier so sieht
würde ich mich nicht denken wenn ihr ihn
kennt der den kennt der die person
vielleicht kennen könnte dann will ich
gern auf instagram and laser luca oder
hier in den kommentaren und leicht wird
es die lovestory und des jahres oder
nicht ich darf wir sind bestimmt für
einander
[Musik]